i lost a bet and you know what that
means
wait wait wait before we get to that not
only have we now donated ten thousand
dollars to save the children they
actually reached out to us the channel
for advice that's right the actual
charity saved the children reached out
saying they needed help getting the word
out that they are not the same thing as
save the kids they have been mistaken
many times and so naturally i wanted to
help and so i told them to highlight the
difference we'd have to create a
marketing campaign that appealed to the
same people that save the kids reached
and so to help spread the word after
weeks of planning we created this
hi i'm coffee zilla my name's ally and
i'm a writer at save the children my
name is ettore on the digital team at
save the children my name is corey i
work on the corporate partnerships team
my name is austin lead multimedia
producer and i support save the children
charity save the children save the
children it's come to our attention that
there's been a lot of confusion thanks
to all the crypto scams so we want to
clear things up save the children had
nothing to do with save the kids token
this is the actual save the children
logo it's a real non-profit that's been
around for more than 100 years helping
children this is save the kids it's not
a charity so don't put your money there
you could be saving the children instead
wow that sounds like something i'd
support and if you feel the same you can
donate at the link below but with that
out of the way there's nothing left to
do but give you guys what you paid for
time to go bald oh no
[Music]
this is terrible oh my gosh it's worse
than i thought this is bad
enjoy it promises made promises kept
well here you go guys this is this is
what you all wanted it could be worse i
guess
besides looking like i'm about to join a
cult it's really not bad and the
important thing is that we raise some
money for charity so thank you so much
for a great year it's the best year of
my life and i'll see you in 2022
[Music]